this morning we have an opportunity to
explore one of the mysteries of space
that is black holes and our guide is dr.
Charles Balin now dr. Balin is a
professor of astronomy and he's also a
leader in an international effort in
finding and identifying black holes he
does this by using a host of
observational methods which he'll be
discussing today as such we are in
excellent hands as he will describe to
us what exactly is a black hole and what
are the tools for finding them so we are
certainly in for a real treat so with
that I would say sit back think about
the heavens and help me welcome
professor bail-in to the podium thanks
Anna and thank you for organizing this
wonderful event so I brought along this
football with which I propose to
demonstrate the basic scientific fact
upon which the whole idea of a black
hole is based and that is simply that
what goes up must come down now like a
lot of scientific facts it's actually
not quite that simple there's there's
the additional fact that the faster you
throw it up the longer it takes to come
down and for those of you who are in
danger of taking a high school or
college physics course I will tell you
that there's a little equation
associated with that fact and you can
figure out how long it will take for a
football to come back down if you throw
it up at a particular rate of speed it's
also true that the whole premise is
actually wrong we live in the space age
and so we send rocket ships up into
space and they don't come back down so
it isn't actually true that what goes up
must come down and in fact if I were to
take this football outside and throw it
up into the air at a very high rate of
speed at for example 7 miles per second
very very fast my arm isn't quite up to
it but perhaps we could get some some
stronger person to do this and throw the
football up at seven miles per second it
would not come back down it would escape
from the Earth's gravitational field
altogether and any given object the
earth for example has a speed with which
if you throw something up it doesn't
come back down that speed is called the
escape velocity because if you throw
something up faster than the escape
velocity you it won't come back down and
again there's a little equation
associated with this you can calculate
the escape velocity for any given object
as i said the Earth's escape velocity is
seven miles per second The Sun has a
stronger gravitational field than the
earth it's escape velocity is bigger
almost a hundred miles per second you
could calculate the escape velocity of a
human being that's fun it turns out it's
about one millimeter per hour and so of
course that's really slow I'm walking
much faster than a millimeter per hour
I'm walking at about a thousand
millimeters per second here and so as
you go through your everyday life you're
walking but you're moving around much
faster than the escape velocity of the
people around you and that's why we
don't feel each other's gravitational
effect and that of course is why people
are not attracted to each other at least
at least not by gravity right and but of
course it is also true that as I as we
move around in our ordinary lives we're
moving much slower than seven miles per
second which is the Earth's escape
velocity and so we do feel a very strong
effect from the Earth's gravitational
field now as I say you can calculate
these escape velocities for any given
object you can also figure out what kind
of object you have to have to have a
given escape velocity and about 250
years ago and otherwise obscure
Englishman named John Mitchell did the
calculation to figure out what kind of
an object would it have to be to have an
escape velocity faster than the speed of
light and so again it did a little
calculation and he discovered that in
order to have a strong enough grab speed
of light is very fast it's 186,000 miles
per second so much faster than the
escape velocity of the earth or the ski
escape velocity of the Sun and he
discovered you'd have to have an
incredibly strong gravitational field to
have an escape velocity faster than the
speed of light but there's no reason
that couldn't happen you just have to
have a very very very dense heavy object
and he speculated a little bit about
what such an object might look like and
he figured look if the gravitational
field is so strong that light can't get
off it then no light comes to you from
that object and you can't see it and it
would be dark and there's where he left
it and at the time there was nothing
particularly special about this and in
fact that is basically the definition of
a black hole it's simply an object whose
escape velocity is faster than the speed
of light he didn't use the word black
hole that wasn't coined until the 1960s
but that was the basic idea and it was
already explored 250 years ago but as I
say nobody thought very much about it it
was just a sort of hypothetical
theoretical application of a set of
equations that people used all the time
it wasn't until Einstein exactly 100
years ago came up with the theory of
relativity that people realized that
this was kind of a
special situation and the reason it was
special is because the speed of light
turns out to be a very very special
velocity and in particular it turns out
that nothing goes faster than light you
cannot go faster than the speed of light
it's the ultimate speed limit so if you
have something whose escape velocity is
greater than the speed of light light
can't come off it but nothing else can
come off it either no information of any
kind and no effect of any kind can come
from an object whose escape velocity is
greater than the speed of light and make
it back to us because the gravity is so
strong that anything that tries to get
off it will fail and will fall back down
now you know Einstein realized Einstein
and the other people studying relativity
realize that this had a very particular
effect this meant that if nothing can
communicate from such an object to the
outside world then in a certain sense
that object isn't part of our universe
what do we mean by being part of the
universe being part of the universe
means something somewhere that might
have possibly in effect on something
that might have an effect on us that you
know just the most distant stars well we
can see them their light comes to us and
even if we can't see them then maybe
something can see them that we can see
and so there would be some way that
information about them could conceivably
come to us and an object whose escape
velocity is greater than the speed of
light isn't like that nothing can come
off of that no information no light no
radiation know nothing of any kind can
come off it so in a certain sense it's
not part of our universe and in fact you
could think of the universe as not being
a big thing but a big thing with holes
in it sort of like Swiss cheese and so
inside are these little pieces cut out
of our universe that don't have any
effect on us at all sort of a bizarre
thought and so the whole idea of what a
black hole is is it simply a big
imaginary circle in space and
properties of that circle is that on
that will interfere really on that
sphere that sphere is where the escape
velocity is equal to the speed of light
and there's some really dense thing
inside here and this is called the event
horizon because any event that happens
inside it cannot communicate in any way
with anything outside it and the radius
of the event horizon is given the name
Schwarzschild radius Schwarzschild was a
scientist who worked on relativity and
then was killed in World War 1 but not
before he calculated what this
Schwarzschild radius might be and inside
the event horizon you're in this sort of
philosophical sense not not part of our
universe and if you nevertheless take
the standard equations and ask well
what's going on inside here you get very
very strange answers for example it
turns out to be the case that inside the
event horizon space and time are
reversed now what could that possibly
mean well think about what what time is
like we're all moving forward in time
we're moving at the rate of one day per
day and and there's not a lot you can do
about that unfortunately if you have you
know a jet engine or something and you
turn it on and you rush off you can't
slow down how fast you're moving in time
you're always moving forward and you're
always moving at the rate of the day per
day on the other hand if you turn on
your jet engine or any other energy
source like the chemicals in my body you
can move around in space I'm doing it
right now I'm walking back and forth I
can walk forward and back I can jump up
and down all by expending energy but you
can't do that with time now inside the
event horizon it's the other way round
nothing you can you always go in the
same direction in space you fall toward
the middle and you will fall and fall to
the exact point in the middle which is
called a singularity after some amount
of time and anything inside the event
horizon will false true
toward the center and if you turn on a
jet engine or other kind of energy
source you don't change that you don't
change that because it turns out as a
disappointed out e equals MC squared and
so the amount of energy that you use to
try and slow yourself down actually
gives you more mass that mass just makes
the gravitational force faster and it
compensates and you fall straight down
toward the center so you're going in one
direction at a given speed in space all
the time but if you turn on that energy
source it turns out it to have to have
an effect and it moves you around in
time this is why the science fiction
writers like like black holes so much or
one of the reasons it's because he gives
you a scientifically certified time
machine and that's important for the
plot of a lot of science fiction novels
what they usually forget to tell you is
that there's this event horizon on the
outside and so if you move around in
time you don't get to come back and
enjoy it and so it doesn't actually do
you any good so there are all sorts of
other things that crazy things that
happen inside the event horizon the
theoretical physicists worry about this
a lot the science fiction writers as i
mentioned worry about this a lot but i'm
neither one of those things i'm an
observational astronomer and at this
point you should be very concerned and
the reason you should be concerned is
that my first two slides contradict each
other completely remember what the title
of the talk was how to see a black hole
I've now just spent the past ten minutes
explaining to you why that's totally
impossible right because the
gravitational field here is so strong
that light isn't going to come up
nothing's going to come up there's no
possible way to see this it's not even
part of our universe and yet I proposed
to spend a whole hour explaining to you
how to see a black hole and that's
basically the topic of my talk how we
know that these things really exist how
we can study them and how you can
actually observe something that's
intrinsically impossible to see
alright so the first step along the way
is just to say that it is the case that
for over 70 years we've known that black
holes should exist they should exist
because there are certain kinds of stars
which are going to inevitably end their
lives in the form of black holes and to
understand this you have to first
understand why it is that every star
isn't the black hole if you think about
it stars have you a star like the Sun
have enormous amounts of gravity they
pull things in really hard and they also
don't have solid surfaces they're not
like the earth they're made up of gas
and so why doesn't every atom in every
piece of gas in a star simply sink to
the center of that star because of the
stars gravitational force and there's a
one-word answer to that question and
that word is pressure and again that's
one of these scientific concepts that
seems simple when you when you name it
but when you think about it a little bit
more it gets more and more complicated
think about a balloon when you blow up a
balloon the elastic in the balloon is
trying to make it smaller but something
is preventing it and the reason it's
preventing it is that there's a little
more air maybe a little bit hotter
inside the balloon then there is outside
and so the air pressure inside the
balloon is greater than the air pressure
outside the balloon and that air
pressure pushes out word against the
force of the elastic pushing it and
basically that's the exact same way
stars work gravity pulls in pressure
pushes out and at every point in the
middle of a star like the Sun those two
forces balance and so the Sun can
happily sit there and shine for five
billion years without getting
particularly smaller or bigger now in
order to make this work it turns out
that in order to have the right amount
of pressure the middle of the Sun has to
be hotter than the outer part of the Sun
that's where the extra pressure comes
from and we know why that is it's
because there's a big energy source down
in the middle of the Sun there's
hydrogen fusion that's how the Sun
shines it's great sort of a big hydrogen
bomb and so there's all this energy
being created in the middle that keeps
the center ha that keeps the pressure
high and that opposes the force of
gravity
and then gradually that radiation will
leak out and that's why the Sun shines
but there's a problem with this in the
long run which is that eventually you
run out of hydrogen you can it turns out
fuse other elements but eventually you
run out of all nuclear fuel in the
middle of the star and then something
has to happen because there's not enough
pressure to hold it up and things start
to collapse so you end up with no fuel
left no pressure the star not no
pressure but not enough pressure to
counteract gravity the star starts to
collapse so here's a smaller star and
eventually that process can stop because
when it got star becomes very very dense
turns out there's a new kind of pressure
that comes in that isn't dependent on
temperature and therefore doesn't need
to have nuclear fusion going on to hold
up the start but that only happens after
it contracted and become very very debt
so the end of the life of a star the
endpoints of stellar evolution one of
them is as what we call a white dwarf
these are very common kinds of stars you
get about the mass of the Sun in a
volume about the size of the earth the
earth is much smaller than the Sun so
that means this is really dense stuff
imagine stuff that's about a ton per
cubic centimeter so very very dense far
denser than any kind of ordinary
material and then you have a whole star
that's that dense these are white dwarfs
and as I say there are actually pretty
common stars because every star like the
Sun is going to end up as a white dwarf
after it runs out of fuel so five
billion years from now the Sun will be a
white dwarf held up by this other kind
of pressure very very dense crushed down
to the size of the earth now turned out
and this is what was discovered 70 years
ago that you can't be a white dwarf if
you're more than 1.4 times the mass of
the Sun because if you're more than 1.4
times the mass of the Sun the the
gravitational force will beat even this
new kind of pressure and the collapse
will continue
and this was discovered by a man named
Chandrasekhar one of the great
astrophysicists of the 20th century I
think I have a picture of him here
there's Chandra as he was known and this
is him as a student at Cambridge
University in England and he was a
student when he made this great
discovery that you couldn't be I'll have
a white dwarf more than 1.4 times the
mass of the Sun and he had an
unfortunate experience he went to
explain his great new discovery as I
said he was a student to the Royal
Astronomical Society which is a big deal
organization in England where the
astrophysicists get together and tell
each other what's going on and so he
explained his whole idea and then his
teacher his thesis advisor a man named
sir arthur eddington very very famous
guy who was supposed to be at the time
the only guy in the world who really
understood relativity except for
Einstein so his teacher then got up and
denounced him very unfortunate
occurrence for young Chandra and
everybody believed the famous teacher
they didn't believe Chandra but Chandra
was right and 50 years later he got the
Nobel Prize for it but there was a kind
of delay before people accepted this
result and here's what Eddington said he
said there ought to be a law of nature
to prevent stars from behaving in this
foolish manner and so Eddington was
convinced that this idea which he
addicted was very smart he realized that
if this was true it meant that black
holes or something like them would have
to exist and he was very disturbed by
that and he figured there had to be some
some law that prevented such a crazy
thing from happening now this is a very
very unscientific thing to say who are
we or who is even Sir Arthur Eddington
to say what nature can and cannot do and
it's a useful thing to remember perhaps
that if Eddington had believed his
student instead of his gut feeling then
we would have started studying black
holes in the 1930s instead of the 1960s
and we'd be 30 years further advanced a
lesson to students and teachers elect
perhaps it turns out there is another
kind of pressure they didn't know that
at the time what
happens if white dwarfs continue to
collapse is that you know that atoms are
made up of electrons and protons and
neutrons and what happens is the
electrons and the protons get all
squished together and turned into
neutrons and then you have basically the
star turns into one big Adam a single
atom with the billions and billions and
billions of neutrons and no protons and
no electrons so it's an atom made up
only entirely of neutrons and you can
get the mass of the star crushed down
into volume all the size of Yale
University about ten kilometers across
and now you've got something that's 100
million tons per cubic centimeter
incredibly dense stuff these things and
then another different kind of pressure
again comes in whoops hello let's cancel
that and all the subatomic particles
crush together to make a single atomic
nucleus and these things are called
neutron stars and they again are known
to exist they're observable in the form
of pulsars they were discovered in the
1960s and this is what prompted people
to start thinking once again about the
possibility of black holes now there's a
problem with neutron stars which is they
have the weird property that the more
massive they are the smaller they become
and it turns out that if they're more
massive than three times the mass of the
Sun if they fit inside their own event
horizon so this is an object that lives
inside the event horizon but anything
that lives inside an event horizon is a
black hole it doesn't matter what it is
it doesn't matter if it's neutrons or
feathers or anything else if it's
smaller than it if it's inside its own
event horizon then you've got yourself a
black hole so if the mass is greater
than three times the mass of the Sun
then the neutron star fits inside its
event horizon and therefore must be a
black hole so just to summarize if
you're less than 1.4 times the mass of
the Sun you end up as a white dwarf if
you're less than three solar masses you
can end up as a neutron star if it's
more than three solar masses left at the
end of the lifetime of the star then
that object once its nuclear fuel is all
exhausted and it doesn't have the
standard kind of pressure anymore has
t'kul
laps to a black hole now you'll notice
the asterisk I've said a couple times
already that these kinds of broad
scientific statements it has to be a
black hole tend to be more complicated
than you think at first and there's an
exception there's a way out of this
being a black hole which is that the
Schwarzschild radii whole idea remembers
that the thing is smaller than its event
horizon inside its own Schwarzschild
radius the Schwarzschild radius
calculation depends on general
relativity being a correct theory so it
might be alternative is that Einstein
could be wrong and in a way this is one
of the reasons it's nice to work on
these things because either it's a black
hole which is pretty exciting or
Einstein's theories the hundredth
anniversary of which we are celebrating
this year might be incorrect and there
might be some better theory that one
would have to figure out which would be
even more excited so either way a
compact object at the end of the life of
a star more than three solar masses is
kind of a fun thing so the trick is
where do you find these compact objects
and how can you figure out how much they
weigh I like to look at objects like
this this is a so-called x-ray binary
this is a double star turns out star
most stars comes in come in pairs our
son is an exception it doesn't have a
companion star good for us it would be a
problem in terms of the seasons for
example if Jupiter were actually a star
and so here's a double star this is an
ordinary star more or less like i should
say this is an artist's conception this
is not a picture taken it a telescope
this is an ordinary star a lot like the
Sun except it has this somewhat weird
shape and what this shape is is that's
basically the same as the tides that's a
big lump that's pulled up on one side of
the star and the reason it is is because
the other star which is down in the
middle here so small you can't see it is
actually more massive than this star is
it's one of these compact objects I was
talking about before and it's got so
much gravity that it's actually pulling
stuff off the surface of the other star
and down on to itself and what happens
to this stuff is there's a gas stream
here and then it goes into this disk and
it goes into orbit around the thing in
the middle and
gradually through friction it spirals in
going faster and faster and falls down
on top of a tiny little star down there
so small you can't see it as the
material spirals in the reason it
spirals in is because there's a lot of
gas there's a lot of friction friction
of course makes heat and it gets hotter
and hotter and hotter and this disk
because so-called accretion disk is much
hotter than the star actually is because
the gravitational force of the thing
it's falling on is so big down in the
middle there these things get so hot
that they don't emit ordinary light they
emit x-rays and these things turn out to
be the brightest sources of x-rays in
the sky x-ray astronomy is kind of a
newfangled science x-rays don't make it
through the atmosphere so you can't
observe x-rays from an observatory on
the surface of the earth because the
x-rays don't make it it's good for us
that x rays don't make it through the
atmosphere the Sun generates x-rays we
would all get radiation sickness if
there weren't the atmosphere it's bad
for x-ray astronomers because it makes
it awkward to build an x-ray Observatory
you can however put an x-ray Observatory
into orbit this has now been done the
Hubble Space Telescope is the most
famous Space Telescope but it's not the
only one and some of the most productive
ones are these x-ray observatories and
if you look at the sky in x-rays from
out beyond the the atmosphere you see
many bright sources of x-rays and the
brightest of them all are these x-ray
binaries and what you're seeing is the
central part of this accretion disk now
when you see that many x rays you know
that the thing that's accreting the gas
has to be a compact object and the
reason you know that is if it was an
ordinary star the gas wouldn't build up
enough energy to create all these x-rays
because x rays are very energetic kind
of radiation so it has to be a compact
object so the question is can you figure
out how much it weighs and it turns out
that that this can be done and what you
do is you watch the other star the
ordinary star as it orbits around this
unseen object and the faster the orbit
goes the more massive the thing it's
orbiting around has to be if the thing
if
the object is pulling you really hard
then you have to move really fast stay
in orbit so if you can measure the speed
where it goes around in its orbit you
can determine the mass of the thing it's
going round that turns out that
measuring speeds measuring velocity is
something we know how to do this is done
using the so-called Doppler shift so let
me briefly explain that and then I'll
demonstrate it here what happens is
supposing you've got a something that's
emitting light waves and it's moving
it's coming towards me here so this
light bulbs going to move and then what
happens is as it moves it emits light
waves the light waves go travel outwards
they travel outwards from where they
were emitted but each time a light wave
is emitted the light bulbs in a
different place so you're going to get a
bunch of expanding waves but each of
them will be centered on a slightly
different place so let me show you how
this works here's the light bulb it's
moving toward me and at each of these
dots it emits a wave and the wave
travels out Burt so when it was at the
purple point it emitted the purple wave
which has traveled the farthest out but
it's centered on the purple but dot and
each one of these dots it emitted
another wave of the color of the dot so
you can see it here and for example this
green one has ended up here and the
Centers of all these outwards going
waves have changed because the thing is
moving so now look what happened if I'm
standing here the waves are coming
towards me and they're very close
together so the wavelength that I
observe is pretty is shorter than it
otherwise would be but if I stood over
here where the object was going away
from me I'd see these waves much much
further apart so the wavelength changes
depending on whether the object is
coming toward you or moving away from
you and if it's coming towards you the
wavelengths get shorter if it's going
away from you the wavelengths get longer
now we can perceive the wavelengths i'm
going to give you an example with sound
waves in just a minute sound waves the
way it works is short wavelengths are
high-pitched noises something like that
a long wavelengths are low pitched
noises things of that nature and so if
something is coming towards you
you'll hear it at a higher pitch than
you thought this is the so-called
ambulance effect I don't know if you've
noticed this with sirens coming down the
street and a sirens coming down the
street at you this way and when it
passes you and starts going away from
you instead of coming towards you the
pitch drops so you're here mm-hmm as the
thing goes past you on the street so I
have a demonstration let's see let's see
if I can get this to work there's a
there's a noise yeah and it's a high
pitch noise and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put this thing in motion
and I'm going to swing it around my head
and what ought to happen is that when it
comes towards you it ought to sample a
higher pitch than when it's going away
from you is it working cool I can't tell
do you understand why I can't tell I'm
in the middle it's not coming to I'm
swinging it around it's not coming
toward me or going away from me and so I
couldn't tell from where I was sitting
it was exactly the same pitch the whole
time as it went around because it's not
coming toward you or away from you uh
let's let's yeah let's try an experiment
I don't know whether this will work but
that's the nature of an experiment
everybody put your hand up but really
quickly up and down yeah up and down
good here's what I want to try and do
when you hear okay you could stop for a
sec when when you hear the thing at its
highest pitch the highest pitch put your
hand up really quickly but only when you
hear the thing when I start swinging it
around when it's really high pitched
let's see if this works
yeah it's okay if there's a tendency for
it to start here and move that way
that's because the things going around
this way and you guys hear it first and
then you do if i swing it the other way
yeah more or less as I say I can't tell
right because I'm standing in the middle
and I don't hear the pitch change at all
so that's how it works with sound waves
light waves work a little differently
because of course you can't hear them
with your ears you see them with your
eyes and short wavelengths are bluer
than long wavelengths that's the
difference between colors blue light is
short wavelength light red light is long
wavelength light so now think what
happens if you look at an object that is
in a an orbit around some other objects
so this object is going around in
circles and sometimes it's here i'll use
the i'll use the the football sometimes
it's coming towards you and sometimes
it's going away from you and when it's
coming towards you it looks a little
bluer and when it's going away from you
it looks a little redder so if you
observe its color over time you can see
first it looks blue when it comes toward
you then it looks red then it looks blue
again and it goes through these cycles
now and so you can measure these things
for if you plot what's called radial
velocity radial velocity means how fast
it's either coming towards you are
coming away from you usually the way
it's set up is negative numbers are
coming towards you positive numbers are
going away from you and you plot that
and measure that you plot it as a
function of time it comes towards you it
goes away from you comes towards you
goes away from you and you can
immediately figure out two things from
making this observation one is the
orbital period how long it takes to go
around one orbit the orbital period of
the earth around the Sun is a year the
orbital period of the moon around the
earth is a month but you can also figure
out how fast it's going it's not quite
how fast it's going it's a minimum speed
because you know it could be going this
way it could be going sideways and where
it never comes towards you or away from
you and so what you measure with radial
velocity is less than might be the true
speed if it's going
around like this or it could be less
than the true speed if it's going around
this way so it's a minimum velocity so
you measure the minimum velocity measure
the orbital period and from those two
things you can figure out the mass of
the other object that's why this is so
great because you can figure out the
mass of something you're not looking at
if you're looking at the thing that's
doing the orbit and you're figuring out
the mass of the thing it's orbiting
around so you observe the companion star
and you figure out what the mass of the
of the compact object in the middle of
the accretion disk is there's a
technical problem turns out the
accretion disk is so bright that you
can't see the other star all that energy
you know but it also turns out that
there's a way that nature has provided
of turning off the accretion disk what
happens is that a lot of these systems
are so-called transients where you get a
little piece of accretion the the
compact object bites a small piece off
its companion star that piece of mass
falls down it lights up you see x-rays
all kinds of fireworks and then it
finishes eating that piece of the star
and then it doesn't eat anymore for
decades and so then they're long periods
where all you see is the companion start
just looks like any other ordinary star
except that you know that it isn't
because you used to see all these x-rays
so here's how you find a black hole
simple 5-step process you wait for a new
x-ray source to be identified that's
when it decides to eat a piece of its
companion you figure out which star in
the sky it is associated with all those
x-rays you wait you wait some more
because you can't do the next step until
the until the outburst has stopped and
then when the outburst is finally over
you may you observe this radial velocity
you observe the Doppler shift you figure
out how fast the start you can see is
going and then you determine a minimum
mass and if that meant in the mass is
more than three solar masses you win
that is to say you discover you have
discovered a black hole because you know
it's a compact object or they wouldn't
have been the x-rays and you've now
measured its mass
to be more than three times the mass of
the Sun so I've done this a few times
and I thought I'd tell you about the
very first time this happened it started
with this this communication here this
is a so called x-ray telegram a x-ray
astronomy telegram what they do is the
there are things going on in the sky all
the cut all the time new comet supernova
novi all kinds of exciting things happen
and you need a way of telling people at
other observatories that something
exciting has happened if you wait two
years to publish your resolve it will be
gone and so that isn't good and so they
had this system setup of telegrams where
you would send in your cool new result
amateurs could do this to you send in
your cool new result to somewhere in
actually it's in Cambridge Massachusetts
as it happens and you send it in and
they circulate it to all the
observatories everywhere in the world
now of course it's done by email but at
the time it was done by telegrams so
here is an astronomical telegram and
there's a whole bunch of astro jargon
down here pay no attention to it the
title tells you everything you need to
know which is that there is and now
these people are announcing that there's
an x-ray transient a new source of
x-rays never before seen in the
constellation of mosca Muska the fly
you've probably never heard of the
constellation of moscow the fly it's
quite obscure for two reasons first of
all it's in the southern hemisphere you
can't see it from here second of all
it's a pretty pathetic excuse for a
constellation it's got you know they
have to call that part of the sky
something but there really isn't much
there there's one pathetic fourth
magnitude star that's why they call it
the fly okay and you can picture how
this looks on the little maps there's
this one star they put wings on it and
call it a fly but nevertheless this
constellation is now one of my favorites
because it contains this object so big
new source of x-rays in Muska in the
southern hemisphere Scott so here's the
picture i started with this is an
observatory in chile in the southern
hemisphere and this big telescope don't
this is actually how the sky looks down
there it's amazing this is the center of
the galaxy this is the Milky Way that's
one of the Magellanic Clouds the closest
galaxies to our own and again that's
something you
only see in the south it's very very
spectacular and this is was at the time
in the early 1990s the most powerful
telescope in the southern hemisphere
just to give you a sense of scale that's
the door that down there so it's a very
big building has a very big telescope in
it just have some here's here's the
telescope itself the way it works is
this in here is a big mirror and the
light comes you this is the dome or the
light comes in from here it bounces off
the mirror that you can't see there i'll
show you the mirror in a minute bounces
up to another mirror here and bounces
back down to here where there's some
kind of camera in this cage it used to
be when they first built the telescope
and they were using photographs
photographic plates to record the data
that the astronomer would ride around in
his cage all night long and so that you
could change the photographic plates and
things by now fortunately there's
electronics down there and there's a
little wire coming off the back here
that leads to a control room where you
can sit where it's warm and it's not
dark and you don't have to ride around
in the dark for eight hours anymore but
very big and and the heart of it is it's
big mirror in the middle here which is a
four meter mirror so it's 13 feet across
perfectly constructed mirror to reflect
the light and so basically what happens
is you get the same amount of light you
would get if you're I was 13 feet across
that's how a telescope work so it
collects lots and lots of light here's
the mirror they took it out to repair
this is the mirror back here it's got a
hole in the middle because the light has
to come back down through and go into
that cage they've taken the shiny stuff
off the mirror it's just a piece of
glass now and they're working on it the
mirror sits on top of this apparatus
here and these things which it sits on
sort of push up on the bottom to keep it
in the right shape because as as you
move the mirror around glass is actually
a little bit of a liquid and it flows
and so you had in order to keep the
right prescription on this mirror you
have to push on the back end and so
these are these little pushers and
they're going to polish that up put it
back on here and put the whole thing
back in the telescope in a little while
anyway so that's the the great for meter
mirror but I'm actually more
interested in this telescope here in the
foreground because this one happens to
be owned by you it's a much smaller
telescope although it works on the same
principles as this one and at the time
shortly after the announcement of these
x-rays I was down in Chile doing some
observing and I decided that the new
x-ray source was actually much more
interesting that the thing that I
thought I was going to observe when I
went down there and so I changed my mind
and did this other thing and here's my
telegram that's me and then again a
whole bunch of Astro jog and pay no
attention to it the key thing is that we
found the star that was emitting all the
x-rays and it and it changed its
brightness every ten and a half hours
and what the outburst was still going on
so we couldn't do the radial velocity
curve or anything but what we think was
happening was most of the light we were
seeing was from the accretion disk but
once per orbit the ordinary star got in
the way and there was an eclipse and
there was a dip in the light and so you
could figure out what the orbital period
was so I had half the information you
need to make this measurement but until
the outburst was over you couldn't get
the radial velocities you needed a
bigger telescope anyway so we applied
for some time on the great big telescope
for the following year to try and make
this radial velocity measurement and we
travel down this is where the
observatory is it's a little north of
Santiago in Chile Chile is this strange
one-dimensional country and up here but
it has these great mountains mountains
in the desert that's where you want to
put your telescope and so here up in the
Andes here is where the Sarah to Lola
inter-american Observatory is and we
traveled down there we had three nights
of observing to make this observation of
what we knew was the orbital period was
ten and a half hours and so we realized
we did a little calculation that if the
difference between how fast the star was
going when it was coming towards you and
how fast it was going when it was going
away from you was 800 kilometers a
second or more than the mass would be
three times the mass of the Sun and it
would turn out to be a black hole so
here's what happened that we went down
there the first night it rained now of
course you put your Observatory in
places where that's not supposed to
happen but
duns it does and it's an occupational
hazard of astronomy that sometimes you
get rain and this is bad because they
don't give you a raincheck you just lose
your night of observing the next night
so we had three nights the second night
it hailed I don't know if you've ever
been inside a hollow six foot six story
high steel building with golf ball-sized
hail stones raining down on it that was
exciting but it didn't get a lot of
science done so now we were worried
because we've lost two of our three
nights and you know they give you these
places to sleep little dormitories which
because you have to sleep in the daytime
and so they're light tight and sound
tight nothing gets into them there's
these little boxes and you wake up in
the late afternoon at four thirty in the
afternoon having gone to sleep at dawn
and you open the shutter and there's
this moment where you look out at the
sky and you think am I going to be able
to accomplish anything tonight
unfortunately on the afternoon of the
third night it turned out fortunately
for us that the storm had passed it was
clear so we were going to have one night
of observing so i'm going to show you is
what we observed on that one night here
are hours in time ten hours between
sunset and sunrise and here's the radial
velocity of this thing so remember minus
numbers means it's coming towards you
positive numbers means it's going away
from you this is in kilometers a second
and if the difference between when it's
coming towards us as fast as it can and
when it's going away from us as fast as
you can is more than 800 in these units
then it has to be a black hole so here
was the first observation this is
already very good news it's coming
towards us at 250 kilometers a second
and things don't usually go that fast
and so the only excuse for something
that's faster than the escape velocity
of the galaxy and so ordinarily stars
don't go that fast and so that shows
that it's in a very tight binary orbit
with something else so the basic idea is
more or less correct and then we
observed a few more points and by now
it's perfectly clear that it has to be a
binary star because the first
observation it's coming towards us at
250 kilometers a second now it's going
away from us at 200 kilometers a second
so it's gone around a large fragments in
two hours we've been observing it it's
going
around a big fraction of its orbit so
then more points were observed and now
it's midnight and now we're pretty happy
because it's going away from us at over
400 kilometers per second now we and we
think it's a 10 and a half our orbit so
five hours ago which is down here
somewhere it was probably going towards
us at 400 kilometers a second but we
couldn't observe it then because the Sun
was still up so we haven't quite got the
proof but it sure looks promising and so
we were very enthusiastic but you know
things happen at this point there was a
small earthquake and chill a is prone to
this kind of thing and earthquakes do
bad things to precision aligned optics
and so we kind of sobered up fast put
the telescope back together again but it
is true that the next point is
discordant it sort of got got out of
whack and then there's an hour long gap
which we don't actually explained in the
paper we subsequently published while we
sort of straightened everything out and
got it working again and now it's
clearly what's happened is it was going
away from us as fast as you can and now
it's kind of in this part of it to orbit
here and we observed more points for the
rest of the evening and things seem to
be going well and now that now it was
sort of almost back to where it started
so it started coming towards us then it
went away from us for a while now it's
coming towards us again and we really
wanted one more point because we figured
it'll be down here and that's the thing
we need to prove that it's 800
kilometers a second different from this
to up in here and you know this point we
kind of throw out because that's the
earthquake point but there's a problem
which is you know objects rise in the
east and they set in the West and so as
we've been watching this for almost 10
hours now the objects gone up come down
and now it's setting into the West and
this telescope is having to point closer
and closer to horizontal to follow it
now remember what that mirror looked
like it's not bolted down it can't be
bolted down because bolts change
their size a little bit when the
temperature changes and so if you bolt
the thing down it'll squeeze on the
mirror and bend it out of shape so it
just sits on top of those pads so now
this mirror is sitting on top of the
pads the pad and the telescope's doing
this and there's a tipping point that's
going to happen at some point and the
mirror is going to fall out and break on
the floor it's very much more than seven
years bad luck if you break the primary
mirror of the largest and most powerful
telescope in the southern hemisphere so
they actually it's interesting they
don't even let the astronomers move the
telescope because we'll screw it up and
so they have these technicians whose job
it is to keep the astronomers in line
and they're the only ones who are
actually allowed to move to telescope so
right around here our techy is telling
us professors you may not continue this
set of observations you are endangering
the telescope this is very very bad you
have to stop now and we said as
scientists do you know-know in the
interest of science we need one more
point down here and we had this big
argument and at a certain point the
techie picks up the phone and starts
this is five in the morning right starts
dialing the home phone number of the
Observatory director another thing
that's really bad is to wake up the
Observatory director at five in the
morning all right so at this point we
said all right all right all right we
give it's over but of course we were
taking data during the argument
and the argument had gone on long enough
for us to get the final data point that
we needed and this is the clinching one
it shows that the end though over
breakfast we figured out exactly what
the best fit sine curve to this was and
here's our telegram again a bunch of
astro jargon the value of the mass
function 3.1 times the mass of the Sun
provides dynamical evidence dynamical
meaning from the motions of the stars
that the primary the more massive object
in the system is a black hole now those
of you who are scientifically inclined
will notice plus or minus point five
here and let me just sit and remind you
that this is a minimum mass and it turns
out there was other evidence that the
angle of the orbit was such that the
mass is actually up around seven but
this is a an absolute minimum to what it
could possibly be and so then we try to
publish our paper the paper was entitled
something like evidence for the
existence of a black hole in the
constellation of mosca we sent it into
nature the editor of nature didn't like
this title the editor of nature said oh
now you know that's an extraordinary
claim to claim something's a black hole
you need extraordinarily powerful
evidence and you haven't taken into
account the fact that Einstein might be
wrong and we said come on we get to
assume that Einstein is correct you know
oh no so we compromised we don't call
these things black holes we call them
dynamically confirmed black hole
candidates
and here they all are there are the one
I've been talking about the one in musk
as one of the is a small system short
orbital period ten and a half hours this
is that these are to scale this is the
Sun and the orbit of mercury this is the
biggest of them has the longest orbit 30
days and by now ten years later they're
over a dozen of these things can
dynamically confirmed black hole
candidates and interestingly there's
also a bunch of things that turned out
not to be black holes that turned out to
be neutron stars instead and that's
great because now finally you can do
science because you've got you know how
science is supposed to work right you're
supposed to have controlled experiments
all this kind of stuff very difficult to
do in astronomy how would you do a
controlled experiment at astronomy you
stick a ball of hydrogen the size of the
Sun and another ball of helium the size
of the Sun you watch them for ten
billion years hard to do but in this
case you can actually start to do
experimental science because you've got
one group of objects that are supposed
to be black holes and another group of
objects that are otherwise extremely
similar that are going to be neutron
stars and so you can reverse the
question the way we've set this whole
thing up we said you know Einstein must
be right so if I times right then these
things are black holes if general
relativity applies then these things are
black holes but you can ask the other
question you could say if these things
turn out not to be black holes then
Einstein is wrong and that's very
exciting because then you got to come up
with a new theory so you better take
these black holes and look for expected
behavior of black holes that you expect
not to see in the neutron stars here's
an example so ask the question do event
horizons exist that's the basic idea of
a black hole is that they don't have a
surface they have an event horizon so
let's take a neutron star in a black
hole and we'll dump gas on it well just
just pour stuff on top of it that's
what's happening in these binary stars
they're pulling material off the other
star the stuff is coming down and one of
two things will happen if it's a neutron
star it'll hit the surface now if you
drop something onto a surface let me
drop something onto a surface
let's see here all right I'm going to
drop this onto the floor it's a piece of
chalk and uh something will happen what
do you think will happen to the chalk
yeah it'll break it'll break for sure
let's try boom eight different pieces of
chalk why why did it break why did it
break it broke because as it dropped
down it got faster and faster and then
when it hit the floor it couldn't go
anymore and so it had pulled together a
lot of energy because it was moving fast
when it hits the floor can't move
anymore that energy has to do something
else the energy broke the chalk apart
and so if gas is falling oh I'm in the
way of the neutron star alright if gas
is falling onto the neutron star and it
hits the surface and stops the energy
that it carried has to do something it
can't break the neutron star the neutron
stars too tough for that and so what it
does instead is it heats up the surface
of the neutron star and the neutron star
starts to glow and it gets so hot that
it glows in x-rays and so you get extra
x-rays not just from the accretion disk
but also from the surface layer the
so-called boundary layer because the
energy that all this gas had it turns
into radiation now what happens if you
drop stuff on a black hole if that had
been an event horizon instead of a
surface the chalk wouldn't have broken
because there was no moment at which the
energy would have had to turn into some
other form instead what happens is it
just falls right through and the energy
e equals MC squared again the energy
contributes to the total mass of the
black the black hole the black hole
doesn't care whether it's math comes in
the form of what we think of a mass or
in some other form like energy and so
there's no boundary layer x-rays until
you make a very clear prediction if
event horizons exist then the
dynamically confirmed black hole
candidates ought to be less bright than
the neutron stars because the neutron
stars will have this extra source of
x-rays
so here's data from the Chandra x-ray
observatory and what they've done is
they plotted the luminosity how brightly
in x-rays it is against the orbital
period and these dark circles forget
about the extra circle that's just the
data that we're presented in the
particular paper but these black circles
are all black holes and sorry
dynamically confirmed black hole
candidate and these open circles are all
neutron stars and the important thing is
that this is a so called logarithmic
plot here from this tick mark to that
tick mark is a factor of a hundred so
something that here is a hundred times
brighter than something's here and so
you can see you can drive a truck
through this right the neutron stars are
systematically a hundred times brighter
than the black holes are and so this
suggests that it really is true that
these things that are more than three
times the mass of the Sun and so on and
so on really have really don't have
surfaces they really do have event
horizons through which material can pass
out of our atmosphere out of our
universe even so here's where we stand
this is the situation now we now have 14
dynamically confirmed black hole
candidates I should also say something I
haven't discussed at all in this talk
there are now equally good evidence for
what's called supermassive black holes
these are things that are not a few
times the mass of the Sun but billions
of times the mass of the Sun and sit in
the Centers of galaxies and there's now
good equally good evidence for these
supermassive black holes and when you
look at the detailed behavior of these
things you know how bright they are what
kind of radiation they give off it does
seem to be in a court with the ex with
expectations in particular with the
expectation that event horizons exist
and so now as I said just a minute ago
we now it you know ten years ago it was
exciting to find something that probably
was a black hole and so we did that a
bunch of times but it's only after
you've found a bunch of these things
that you can really start to try and
understand them because the way you try
and
stand these things is not just to
discover them but to compare them to
each other and to compare them with
other kinds of objects to try and figure
out really how they work and that's the
process that we're now in a position to
really start and I'll just close by
putting up this this website which is a
place that I've written down a whole
bunch of stuff about black holes so if
you want to get more information that's
a good place to start so thank you and
I'm happy to answer any questions